so when we were coming up with the idea
for this conversation
um we really we both knew immediately
that we wanted to talk about this idea
of resisting dystopia both in the real
world context but also in fiction
um and so I want to start by asking you
about what what do you think dystopia is
and what does it mean to be resisting it
like what is this thing that we're
talking about that we want to push back
on
so uh the very easy question of how to
Define dystopia
dystopia is a world that is
fundamentally broken it is a world in
which
um compassion is thin on the ground it's
a world in which
no one wants to live and in fact it's
quite difficult to do so
um it's a place in which survival is the
only end that you really have the
ability to fight for
um
resisting it resisting it does not mean
uh we're just going to tell a story
about somewhere else we're just going to
close our eyes and stick our fingers in
our ears and uh focus on you know the
most rose-colored glasses version of
this instead resistance is action
resistance is struggle resistance is a
fight so if you are going to resist
dystopia resist
um oppression resist fascism any of
these things that are very much part of
the world as we live in now
um it requires effort and it requires
honesty uh and a lot of other traits
that we're going to talk about in the
next 58 minutes or so
I wanted to add to that that
um one of the things about dystopia is
that it is a real world phenomenon it's
something that we associate with fascism
and oppression and closed regimes but
it's also a type of Storytelling and you
know as science fiction writers we are
immersed in a world where people often
tell us that dystopian writing is the
most realistic kind of writing and that
if we want to tell a story that is going
to help our readers our audiences
grapple with what's going on in the real
world we need to tell them a dark
up story where everyone dies and the
world is ashes at the end
um I once went to a hacker conference
where people were talking a lot about
the Grim meat hook future and
um that's basically you know I think
held up as this ideal in in narrative
and so I think part of resisting
dystopia isn't just the hard work of
politically existing in the real world
but also resisting the urge to turn our
stories about the future into these very
one note
non-nuanced visions of where humanity
and our world could go so that's another
piece of what we're resisting in our
work I think absolutely I mean the real
world and fiction go hand in hand they
are they are
um an arroboros
um I have a real bone to pick with
um this thing that is is very common in
the here and now and not just in
um Science Fiction and Fantasy but in
storytelling as a whole right now this
idea that that cynicism equals
sophistication right that if we're going
to tell stories to adults for adults
that it has to be the Grim meat hook
future
um that this is inevitable somehow I
think that that is uh
just profoundly wrong it's profoundly
wrong on every level because
um you're you're you're creating this
self-fulfilling prophecy you're saying
that hope is something that belongs to
children that Joy is something that
belongs to children and if that's the
case what are we fighting
four like what's the point you know I I
really think that just breathes nihilism
if the only stories we are telling about
the future even if it is in a fictional
context because if the only places we
are imagining and escaping to are places
in which the grimmest possibility is the
only outcome
what do we have to hope for what do we
have to live for you know and so that's
where I think I'm biased of course but
why I think it's important
um not to say that those kinds of
stories don't have value sometimes in
order to confront
um things that are horrifying things
that um are real and scary and damaging
we do need to lean in to that you just
need to sometimes grab it by the caller
and look at it in the face as hard as
you can but if you don't have a
Counterpoint to that
um I think it just starts to poison you
after a while which you know sugar does
too if all you had was
if all you had was hopeful stories if
all you had was and everything works out
and they all lived happily ever after
that's not going to help you out either
but I think you know the the basis of a
nutritious fictional meal is to have
um I didn't mean to keep continuing with
this metaphor but here we are uh but you
know to have a healthy balanced
ecosystem of Storytelling you've got to
have the other side as well yeah I'm
still really disappointed about the
whole thing where you can't just eat
sugar all the time so you know thanks
for
bringing it down
um but I think I mean to continue with
what um Becky's saying I think what's
really important I think for both of us
in our fiction is avoiding a binary
where there's either dystopia or Utopia
because I think that's the other trap
that we get into as storytellers not
just as fictional storytellers but also
as people who are trying to innovate or
people who are trying to you know write
non-fiction about the future is that
we're sort of told okay it's either
going to be all sugar or it's just going
to be this realistic Grim future and the
fact is that the future is going to be
just as messy and nuanced as the present
you know there's going to be people
doing really cool stuff there's going to
be people trying to kill the people who
are doing the cool stuff and the there's
going to be everything in between right
there's going to be mixed spaces where
lots of those people come together and
so I often tell people that I'm a topian
writer which means I'm just writing
about a place like now
um and you know one of the the things
about dystopian writing and for a minute
I want to pick on a specific example
because a lot of people have been
revisiting the handmaid's tale for
obvious reasons not just the television
show but also real world politics and
one of the things that Margaret Atwood
has said about that book is that she
sees it as realistic because every
single thing in it has happened at some
point in history which is actually
unrealistic because there's no point in
history when every single bad thing ever
happened all at once
um and I'm not and this is not to pick
on on that book I mean it's a fantastic
book it's an incredibly useful allegory
for us to think about what's happening
to women's bodies and women's rights but
in terms of what dystopia is it reminds
us that dystopia is an allegory you know
it's just a fantasy or a fable it's not
an actual real world scenario